[Music]
[Applause]
uh that that segues nicely into Tim
Hasselbeck ESPN uh analyst former NFL
quarterback you can see him on this just
in a two Eastern on the mothership NFL
live at four Eastern Tim was uh cut on
Hard Knocks when he was with the Ravens
and um
now do you have any any say in that
footage being aired that you get I mean
it's humiliating enough to get cut but
you got cut on TV with cameras rolling
no I had no say Dan the funny thing
about it was actually was cut by the
bills I don't know three weeks prior
right so like that one hurt my feelings
I was like man I don't know I'm ever
gonna recover from this and then I go to
the arrangement there's hard knocks and
it's like cameras following you around
everywhere and I'm sitting there and
Brian bilox like hey man like this
doesn't mean it's forever
but to make it worse literally to make
it worse I don't know if it was scripted
to this like totally humiliate me it was
like a big a big van like oh it's not
bad like a bus like a like a coach bus
that probably seats 65 people
I wrote it by myself through the airport
like it was like how much salt do you
want to pour into the wound fellas golly
as you can tell as you can tell I'm over
it I'm over it is there an easy easier
way to cut people
or a worse way to cut people I mean this
is it's it's TV and they're trying to
make good TV and I'm sure it was good TV
yeah no I think that's a good point my
situation was this like I actually knew
I wasn't going to make the team right
like it was Randall Cunningham Elvis
gerbach Chris Redmond was there like I
was at Camp arm for sure Matt Kavanaugh
was the quarterback coach and he was
actually a teammate with my dad at one
point at the Giants so like I had a good
relationship with him so I was like Hey
like y'all cutting me this week or next
week like I knew I was out but like but
I still don't know if there's like an
easier way to do it to be like hey man
like come on in here like you're out
like you're fired you're out we don't
want you here like I think no matter how
delicate you are with it how much you
know that it's coming it still sticks
okay the Jets make up you got a lot of
young players
and you got a young coach and then you
got Aaron Rodgers help me understand if
you're hard knocks what would you be
focusing on and how do you think that
affects a team like that
yeah well listen I definitely think it
can affect the team people can say
whatever they want like everyone is
fully aware of the cameras fully aware
of them and and then when stuff airs
just because of the nature of some of
the things that they give access to
you know like you'll hear a Personnel
meeting or coach is talking about a
practice like listen you know football
players come across as like tough guys
whatever but man guys are sensitive so
the minute you know they hear a
conversation that you know isn't
complementary
guys catch feelings fast and so I think
that you know what things you want to
focus on probably if it were me like how
people are responding to Aaron you know
like like what Aaron's interaction is
with young players you know our guys uh
you know how do they respond if he yells
at them things of that nature I would
focus on um but I also think too like
I'd be shocked if you get a lot of
access to Aaron right and so it's gonna
be everybody around them see I think
that Zach Wilson would be the
fascination for me with Hard Knocks that
I would focus on him almost as you know
trying to learn absorb whatever he can
from Aaron Rodgers
what do you think of that that plot uh
Alyssa I think it's a great idea because
I think you would learn and honestly
just because it's access that other
people want to get it would tell the
rest of the league a lot about Zach
Wilson right so if his future is not
with the Jets how Zach handles interacts
absorbs everything I think if I were
somewhere else would give me a lot of
information whether or not I was going
to let him try to revive his career
where I was how does it not go well for
the Jets
you know I
I change they'll be
um like a likelihood of you know some
type of growing pain and then I would
also say this Dan that I think is is
interesting like the Jets like they
haven't been the biggest game on the
schedule for everybody like I don't care
if like when they play New England like
you know it like it's gonna be oh hey
the greatest coach versus Aaron Rodgers
and then when they play uh Buffalo it's
hey Josh Allen Aaron Rodgers and Emily
like every game on their schedule like
the the volume that the NFL in terms of
how big they make the game that week is
going to be significant so like what is
like just the the emotional stamina that
that football team has when they haven't
gone through it you know with a lot of
young players to be up and kind of like
be the hunted every single week because
Aaron Rodgers is your quarterback and
it's going to feel like the biggest game
of the weekend
we get caught up in chemistry and
Leadership and I always thought like Cal
Ripken once said hey if I go out and
perform
then I'm leading like watch what I do
how I do it and Aaron Rodgers strikes me
as that I don't know if he's a rah-rah
hey guys come on over we're gonna have
beers we're buddies and all those things
as much as he is just watch me do it uh
is that a fair assessment of Roger's
approach to being a quote leader or you
know the focal point of a team
I think that's fair I think what happens
is guys get older it is harder and
harder to be like that hey guys like
we're all hanging out like as you get
older and you're well into your 30s you
know you look back at some of these guys
that are so much younger than you and
like you're just not in the same stage
of life you're not interested in the
same thing you know as a quarterback
like financially you're in a completely
different Stratosphere than a lot of the
guys that you would be hanging out with
and so I think it changes like I don't
care if it was Peyton Manning I don't
care if it's Tom Brady like Tom Brady
early on in New England is going to be
very different relationship than later
in his career in New England I remember
joking with my brother uh when he was at
the Colts he was like look Andrew Luck
is closer to my daughter's age than my
age like you just like it changes and so
I do think like there's a transition to
hey look just follow how we're
practicing how we're getting ready
talking to Tim Hasselbeck ESPN college
uh in college football and pro football
analyst former NFL quarterback you can
see him with uh Max Kellerman this just
ended two Eastern NFL live at four
Eastern give me the good team that could
disappoint like you're not like it
Teeters on wow this could be really good
or it could go south
well I did I mean they're not the best I
don't think the best team in the
division but the Dallas Cowboys right so
the NFC appears to be way more open
right there's all this talk about hey
Mike McCarthy's now going to call the
plays and look Mike McCarthy's a
successful coach won a Super Bowl he
knows a lot of football I think there's
an under appreciation for how good
Kellen Moore was for that offense while
Kellen Moore was calling plays in Dallas
they are second in the league in scoring
to only the Kansas City Chiefs which you
cannot argue how good Kansas City has
been offensively and part of that span
there's there's a Cooper Rush era
inserted in there like I hope people
know like Keller Moore you know kind of
gets run out of town in Dallas how good
he was I think we could see Dallas's
offense take a step backwards but I
think that's a team that obviously
everyone's talking about Philadelphia
and their High aspirations for people
um you know in terms of the 49ers and
how they see them but look like Dallas
should be a good football team and
like that's another team for me like
what does that offense look like like
are they really like are they getting
better or are they taking a step back
um I think they could take a step back
trying to figure out I talk about this
if Patrick Mahomes played for the Bears
he'd be a curiosity he'd be he'd be a
curiosity because they don't have
weapons around him he went to the right
place the the quarterback who goes to
the right place and has the right coach
and the right weapons can dictate how
successful you are
um and I find that interesting that
there are certain quarterbacks who go I
I thought that David Carr had as much
talent as I had seen and he played for a
terrible Houston team uh you know
Russell Wilson went to the right place
at the right time the right coach uh and
I mean the NFL is littered with
quarterbacks who failed but I think we
sometimes forget that that guy was not
in the right Tim Couch goes to the
Browns they're not any good I don't know
if Tim Couch goes to a good team if he
had a great career you ever step back
and go you know just the luck of some of
these guys going to the right place at
the right time well there's no question
about I'll use my brother as an example
here again look my brothers and bring
back he thinks he's getting traded to
Miami and it would have been like Dave
wants that error in Miami instead AJ
feely goes to Miami Burns Out doesn't
work out and he gets to go with Mike
Holmgren and Mike Holmgren you know knew
him he knew that system he had great
success you bring up the point about
Mahomes people forget he was a raw
Prospect really wrong but he goes to in
my estimation that the best
you know situation in terms of a guy
that can coach quarterbacks look at who
Andy Reid has helped play well like
everybody Donovan I mean look Donovan
McNabb AJ feely koi Denver Michael Vick
Jeff Garcia like like to me Andy Reid
has done a remarkable job with so many
quarterbacks and so I think Patrick
going there there's no question that
that's been a benefit to him but yeah
you're exactly right like I thought a
similar thing with with uh Eli Manning
in New York we put so much mentally on
the quarterback with the Giants Eli was
a perfect fit for it he was so smart he
saw things so well Ben Roethlisberger he
was in a situation in Pittsburgh where
they weren't putting as much mentally on
him early on and that was awesome for
Ben because it was Ben throwing guys off
of him because he missed the hot and
then shooting the ball down the field
like that was perfect for Ben so yeah I
I think a coaching fit for where a
player is has a lot to do with that
guy's success just give me a play if if
I said give me you know give me a play
that you called before that the audience
might go oh my God how do you remember
all of that like the verbiage of it yeah
just everything we're in the Huddle all
right let's go huddle up
come on get him here here we go we're
gonna shift uh uh uh a right uh slot
um 322 Scout why stick lion uh alert
pullback 40. all right on one right but
here we go something like that Hey look
it's been a long time yeah like that
listen I probably just sounded like I
got like a shift and a formation
and and all that did you call two plays
there
uh I did like an alert to to a draw but
like you know what's funny is I always
like think about this and quarterbacks
would gripe all the time especially like
a West Coast offense you literally tell
everyone what to do like I remember
sitting in quarterback meeting rooms and
be like hey can't these guys
like why do I get to tell everybody
everything that they've got to do did
your voice ever crack at the line of
scrimmage
oh listen there there was there was no
question it would crack I I one of the
things we did that's another uh Giants
uh experiment we were playing the Colts
and you know one of the things the
defense would do when they were playing
Peyton Manning is they would hold their
disguise not based on what the offense
was doing but on the play clock so the
defense was actually playing it paying
attention to the play Clocks you're
gonna hold your disguise until the ball
had to be snapped because Payne was just
trying to read your mail so we're doing
Scout teams like just say nonsense you
know I just was like yelling anything
um to kind of go through it and uh like
at the time I had like little kids you
know so like I'm up there and like you
know I'm running out of things to say
you know I mean I'm like you know hey uh
whatever you know Dan Patrick Dan
Patrick you know hot round hot round but
they're like running out of things to
say and like my daughter was like two
years old and I'm like
you used to say the craziest thing I'm
sure there's a lot of cracking going on
there too but Peyton changed how many
quarterbacks truly changed the game
in your opinion in the modern era well
Peyton no doubt did Brady for sure did
the two things that those guys did
um better than anyone that I and I think
Peyton was getting a lot of credit for
for a long time because it was so
demonstrative at the line of scrimmage
was getting into the right play up at
the line of scrimmage right like it was
you know I joke with Jeff Saturday all
the time I'm like you guys ran the ball
well because Peyton never had you run
into a bad luck you know but like so he
was so good at Brady the same thing he
would see something see a blitz and
adjust the protection you know like you
go back further it was hey a team was
blitzing you you just throw hot well
then people started to trap stuff you
know off of a blitz and so now it was a
quarterback was like oh hey you want to
come after us like we're gonna block it
up now and push it down the field so so
those guys most certainly did and then
obviously now with the way
um you know design runs are becoming
much more of a thing for quarterbacks
and how that has to be defended
um that's changing the game again too
yeah I still look at you know Montana
did with the West Coast offense but you
know he probably shared that uh you know
with his coaches but Dan Marino to me
changed he was doing what you guys are
doing now and he was doing that back in
the 80s you know five wide and you know
shotgun
I mean I don't know what he would do
today Dan Marino from the 80s playing
today
would be pretty scary yeah I I think
you're right about that I'll give you
another guy I think change the game a
little bit too is
um Kurt Warner well Kurt Warner in
Arizona okay so like The Rebirth of Kurt
Warner and I think Mourinho in this
environment would have been remarkable
you basically get into a spread set so
whether it's two by two like you're
talking about four wide receivers two by
two set and you could just call some
type of scan protection okay where the
quarterback has control of where he's
going to put the back so if there's an
overload Blitz somewhere you can pick it
up and then you give full autonomy to
the quarterback to Signal the route he
wants I mean that's what happened when
Kurt Warner I think oh people understand
like I think he's in large part in the
Hall of Fame because of what he did at
the end there obviously there was the
Rams but like like that birth with
Arizona was they would call a scam
protection Kurt would get up there and
look at it and like he was playing arena
football again he was looking he was
signaling over here signaling over here
if you put Mourinho in that type of
environment like good Lord like I think
that he would just be shredding people
and Karen Warner once told me he said I
welcomed the blitz because all I needed
to know is where it was coming and then
I was gonna I was gonna you know hurt
you and and you know because normally a
quarterback's like oh I'm gonna get
blitzed he was like no I welcomed it
because it meant there was an opening
there and he took advantage of it there
was opportunity a couple things I'll say
about that with Kurt like he I got like
his toughness in the pocket like you
only want people to come after you if
like you're all right getting drilled in
the chest as you throw like an Inca but
so two things that allowed Kurt to want
that is one he has so much courage in
the pocket he'd stand in there with
anybody and then his ability to
anticipate was so good because Kurt
didn't have this big huge arm he had
plenty of arm but it wasn't a huge arm
but what he had probably better than
anybody I'd seen was he could throw the
ball so early and anticipate where that
guy would be and so like that that is
how you take advantage of stuff down the
field when they're because they're
vacating that that defense down the
field where the ball is out and then
Here Comes Larry Fitzgerald running into
that window let's do this again a great
appearance Tim we really appreciate you
sharing some knowledge thank you very
much yeah good to be honest with you
guys see ya Tim Hasselbeck ESPN college
football analyst and former NFL
quarterback and of course got cut on
Hard Knocks you know it's got to be bad
enough so he got cut and then three
weeks later he gets cut on national TV
Tim will be on uh this just ended to
Eastern and NFL live at four Eastern
take a break we're back after this